[Music]
thank you
Fraser John thank you for joining
spectator TV this week Fraser we're back
to Tory's Psycho Drama it's been a
couple of weeks
how damaging do you think this latest
episode is Boris Johnson's decision to
step down not alone but with two of his
backers therefore meaning free
by-elections for rashishunak well I do
think that this is quite damaging
varicious because his whole promise to
the country was that he was the The
Bookmark the era of Tory Psycho Drama
that chapter had closed and he was going
to open a new chapter of stability and
this was the point where it was changed
and now when the conservatives as a
party just look like a warring tribal
mess yet again
um and one of the things you see in your
cover of story Katie is a cookie even
worse and of course we all know that
when Richardson neck became leader he
was in his own words put in rather than
one election so he knew that he couldn't
really get into much of a personal
mandate he was the loser not the winner
of the contests with members and and so
he figured he had to keep all of his
various Tory factions happy so you can
see in his cabinet this was not a sunec
cabinet this was what he thought was a
truce brokerage between various warning
Tory tribes they all got their man in a
certain position and that would be fine
of course what borders Jones once it was
his honors list so
um all along where she's been sort of
waiting and waiting and waiting and now
he said sorry Boris you're not going to
get things that you want to specifically
Nadine Doris into the House of Lords and
at which point and Boris decides okay
that's it it's war and then we see the
sheer power of Tory spite now looking at
this is it's pretty weird do you think
what's boris's agenda what does he
actually want to achieve is he trying to
get I don't know Ben Wallace in his
leader or something like that and the
more you ask questions the more you find
out there is no agenda other than simply
to weaken Rishi sinek and to
re-establish in the public mind the
words conservative and shambles and to
make it harder for a synag to claim that
she has been able to move on now I would
enter this the financial backdrop of the
guild markets really quite significant
and there was a few weeks when trust was
prime minister where we were saying okay
Liz trust puts up the guilt rates look
at this it's 4.3 percent the markets are
are pushing up everybody's mortgages she
has to go she has to go because the
markets say uh Rishi sunec he'll be the
market Whisperer as soon as he comes
along he'll tell the markets
everything's going to be fine and
they'll calm down now that was The
Narrative of the end of last year but
now the inflation expectations are going
up the guilt yards are going up all of a
sudden people think that Bank rates are
going to Peak at 5.75 percent the new
mortgages if you're trying to buy a
house right now incredibly expensive so
sunak has failed on two of his main
pledges one that he'll count the markets
to the okandatories
John when it comes to I suppose how the
public look at this do you think your
average voter will tell the difference
between Boris Johnson causing problems
to Rishi sunak and general Tory problems
we saw Richard synack this week uh
ultimately hit back at Boris Johnston
Monday when he's speaking at Tech week
Boris Johnson asked me to do something
that I wasn't prepared to do because I
didn't think it was right and if people
don't like that then tough has won some
praise from his party but I do wonder
how much cut for it has more generally
well I think the first thing we have to
ask ourselves is how much cut through
all of this is having uh with the wider
public we've not had much opinion
parting so far
um but we've had three opinion polls
come out that were conducted wholly or
partly since boys Johnson's resignation
was announced on Friday evening together
with that somewhat incendiary
resignation statement
and it has to be said that so far
conservative support has not gone up and
it's not gone down
um and perhaps we should remember that
given the conservative party is already
at a pretty low point in the opinion
polls there is perhaps a limit to the
damage that can be done now I hear a lot
of what phrases says and clearly the
by-elections are unwelcome clearly any
discontent within the party that is
unwelcome but I suspect that so far as
the longer term future of the
conservative party is concerning the
British is concerned it's what's
happening to inflation it's what
happening to interest rates that is
probably the biggest story so far as
those prospects are a concerned because
in the end Mr Sonic one of the things
he's staked his reputation on so far is
the public is concerned is
um getting inflation done and by
implication there so also beginning to
get uh interest rates down now while in
a sense the economy so far has not done
as badly as either the bank of England
or the obr were anticipating for the
early months of this year the inflation
numbers are not so good and that could
mean in the end of course the
conservatives difficulty suffice living
standards next year
against that
um you know
my my honest feeling about the whole
Boris Johnson thing is that Boris
Johnson is an outcome focused person he
wants to achieve what he wants to get
done now for a long time that worked
fine so if you proud Parliament
um and even though in the end the courts
say that you did what you did was
illegal you don't suffer politically
because at least half the country I.E
those who wanted brexit to be
implemented were in favor of what he did
was anybody going to question debatable
procure public procurement policies
during the covert pandemic no we all
wanted the pandemic to be sorted sooner
rather than later and in the end the
bets on the vaccines worked but where
did Mr Johnson and political fortunes
begin to unravel well what was it it was
trying to bend the rules to enable a
conservative MP who had been found to
have broken the rules on lobbying uh to
be saved from his punishment now one
thing we know there is no public
constituency out there that says we
should make life easier for MPS who have
second jobs and we're quite happy to see
the rules broken or to do so and frankly
I don't think there's much of a
constituency out there that believes
that the rules on the on the on the
delivery of honors should be uh bent in
other words the causes Bell eye that Mr
Johnson is now pursuing looks to me as
fragile as the one with their own
partisan Affair let alone uh the
position uh over over party gate and I
so beyond that I would say at the end of
the day you know if Mr cynic is going to
have any chance at all of being able to
win the next election one of the things
you is going to have to do is to draw
pretty substantial clear blue water
between both the Johnson Administration
and the trust Administration and it may
well be that in the longer run this
actually will enable him to do so
certainly if in the end when we see the
report from the Privileges committee and
if it says Christmas we anticipate and
the Prime Minister basically indicates
that he accepts the Judgment of the
Privileges committee that may well help
him in that endeavor and Fraser this is
an argument we hear from optimists
surrounding Rishi sunak which is
effectively if you look at what came up
as the most frequent complaint during
local elections uh according to many
cancers out on the doorstep and and
others it was uh Liz truss Boris Johnson
The Fallout
and Richard has already differentiated
himself from Liz truss in terms of a
different economic approach even though
as you point out the guiltyards are now
back to similar levels and secondly he
has now perhaps through the intervention
this week distanced himself from Boris
Johnson so there is a chance this could
be a moment where he manages to actually
get rid of those ghosts from the past
well he certainly is confronting Boris
Johnson directly in a way that he hasn't
done before until this week he's tend to
just not mention his predecessor at all
and now
um when he was in his speech a few days
ago he was saying well I wasn't
basically I wasn't going to promise um
something I wasn't going to be able to
deliver I.E in the endurance we get a
later peerage rather than an immediate
one so he has started to
um I think he thinks it's safe and I
think he's right to say but it is safe
to pick a fight with the remaining
Johnson lights because there aren't that
many of them I mean the ones that are
there have basically resigned their
seats and caused him lots of violation
pain but as a faction in the political
party they are quite small so there
still is a path to victory for Richie
snake but that's a path which was always
narrow and it's got a lot more narrow in
the last few weeks previously you could
see his narrative it was well I came
leader when we were 30 points behind
labor now it's 15 points behind and if
we manage to get this to a 10 points and
deficit by the new year then the
election becomes contestable and who
knows what could happen but for that he
he needed a whole bunch of things to go
right he needed the Rwanda deportations
to start happening the small boats to um
stop
um arriving you needed inflation to have
by the way it's still forecast to have
but it's going to be a lot tighter than
you originally thought he needed the
Tories to stay um United behind the
belief that he might win if they behave
themselves and he needed the economy to
not collapse and at least give him the
ability to say that he had economic
prowess and that he would stop you know
your mortgage rate is going up all of a
sudden a bunch of these things are
looking a lot more questionable so that
narrow path has become even more narrow
still possible but
um I would say there's about a 20 25
chance of that happening now
now John let me look ahead to those free
by-elections to a definite Dean Doris is
taking her time she's considering her
options as I say in the cover piece and
one Minister asked um will Nadine Doris
just stay in the House of Commons now
until she gets that period almost a
threat to Richie see an act to play ball
um but she may she may trigger her
by-election or at least start the
process so it goes near a tour Party
Conference but working on the Assumption
we're heading to all three so at
Uxbridge Selby and mid bedfordshire
watching the Tory's chances are do you
think it is a reasonable expectation
scenario that they could lose all three
there's a risk that they could lose all
three but there's also a possibility
that they could at least hang on uh to
one of them perhaps not least because of
the reluctance of the opposition parties
uh to be able to come to an agreement
about how to divide the cake between
them
um Oxbridge looks by Far and Away the
most difficult to defend yes it's true
Lord Ashcroft did do a poll recently in
which he suggested that perhaps Boris
Johnson himself might be able to defend
the seat but the honest truth is you
know this is a constituency that we
would expect labor to win if they were
on course in a general election uh to be
winning an overall majority uh the swing
required is seven and a half percent
um and the current swing in the opinion
polls is more of the order of 14 in
other words he needs little more uh
labeling little more than half the
current swing in the National polls and
sometimes of course the swinging by
elections is well the greater are done
in the National polls so I think Arts
British by far away the most difficult
in contrast
both Selby and mid beverton and they're
both seats were labor start off second
but they start off a long second way off
uh Selby the swing required is 18 in mid
bedfordshire it's 19 so here we need if
labor are going to win the seat a bigger
swing than the current national polls
are pointing to and that so far is
something that labor have not managed to
achieve uh in this Parliament I mean
even in a victory uh such as Wakefield
we didn't see anything particularly
spectacular beyond the current position
of the parties in the opinion polls
um
so that but that said I mean again I
think there's no important distinction
between uh these uh two constituencies
Selby and mid bedfordshire
um Selby does have a record of Labor
voting in the past now it's you you have
to know your onions to spot it but
because Selby was only created as a
constituency in 2010 but if we go back
to the estimates that were made of what
would have happened in the constituency
if it had existed in 2005 they suggest
that labor would have only been four
points behind in the constituency and I
think therefore by inference Tony Blair
would probably have won it in 1997 and
2001. so you know not a constituency
would normally expect labor to win but
at least there is a recent history of
people in the area voting labor in not
inconsiderable numbers it's also by the
way a relatively strong Pro leave see
about 58 leave last time that you might
think is good news for conservatives no
it's not it's bad news it's very here
from the local elections now and we know
this also from what's going on in the
opinion polls the concerns are losing
ground more heavily the more pro-leave a
constituency is mid bedfordshire it's
not certainly not a classic blue wall
seat of the kind that we say that would
have got so focusing on voted narrowly
for brexit Liberal Democrats are a third
however if you can do the com do the go
back all the way back to 2005. this is a
constituency worth and what Democrats
were ahead of Labor in 2005. so labor in
other words have never done particularly
well in this constituency so you can see
why the liberal Democrats kind of fancy
their chances and look as though they're
determined to fight the seat hard in a
way that I suspect they will not find
Selby and the 64 000 question is what
will labor do labor are certainly saying
and I'm not surprised about this that
those implicit deals that were done over
Wakefield in Tiverton for example
they're not going to be done now because
of course labor want now to convince
people they can win a general election
and they can win big and kind of
standing down for one of your fellow
opponent opposition parties doesn't look
to be consistent that message so I
wouldn't be surprised if in the end both
of them fight hard as a result voters
don't necessarily work out which of the
two of them is better able to defeat the
conservatives and although the
conservative vote might go down quite
considerably this perhaps is the one
seat that in the end the conservatives
might hang on to so in other words
Nadine Doris may find that thanks to the
opposition she at least doesn't do quite
so much damage to what she saw like as
she intends finally Fraser do you think
Nadine will have her revenge
so I think Nadeem will have her revenge
or she's taking it she's taking her
revenge now certainly but I think it's
your milk for for quite some time I'm
not sure how many people are going to be
swayed by her narrative this little girl
from Liverpool all she ever wanted was a
place was the House of Lords and that
was cruelly denied her
um but I mean I I noticed it seems to me
to be the most indefensibly
self-indulgent I think they're I think
MPS should just not have the option of
getting bored and resigning halfway
through it's a serious thing standing
for Parliament if you're not prepared to
commit to your constituations to serve
out the term no matter what you
shouldn't have a goal to stand forward
to election so she's putting politics
and distribute let alone the
conservative party so I think Nadine
really is not helping herself and and
she so I think ultimately she will end
up with more damage on her reputation
than Rishi sunequal thank you Fraser
thank you John
[Music]
foreign